今からこの家にトミックさんが来ます
まじ久しぶりなんだよねー
今回は結構多いですよ
ライター
何これ
アヒル
はいというわけでこちらの品々々（？）
品々でございます
こちらにある物全部
Amazonの検索で”電気ショック”って打って
電気ショック流れそうなの全部買いました
ちょっと１個ずつ見ていきましょう
やっぱ仕掛ける側として安全かどうかをちゃんと確かめないといけないから
まずはこれだ
マジックですね
これはどうやったら出るんだろう
うわ俺全部食らわないといけないのか
どうやったら出るんだろう
どうやって出るかがわからないよ
これでも出るってこと？
え、待って俺電気ショックやなんだけど
刺したら刺したら
うわ！？いやだ
あれ？出ないじゃん
え、これどうやったら出るの
ショックマーカーって書いてあるから出るはずなんだけど
これはｧ...わかりません
次
電卓なんですけど電気ショックが出る　と
押した瞬間かなぁ？
なん...わかっててやるのが一番いやなんだ
絶対これだ　　　　　あっ！いでぇ〜！！
次はこちらです
これはなんだ？
ライトだな
これライトですわ
うわこれ絶対これだ
もうもう分かった
どっちかのボタンを押すと絶対電気が流れる
間違いない　　あっ！いででででで
こっちはライトだこっちはライトなんですけどこっちを押すと電気が流れます
ターゲットを仕掛ける前に俺がくたばっちまうよ
痛い！わかった
わかった　わかった
今のでわかった
わかってなかったね
赤いとこを押し込むと電流が流れます
やばいちょっと体が持たん
そしてもうすぐ来そうなのでちょっと早めにやっちゃいましょう
次
アヒル製の電気ショックキーホルダーでございます
アヒルのは羽がおかしいんですよね黄色になってるんで
これは引っかからないと思うどうやったら流れるんだろう
やだなー
もう電気やだ　　いでで！
ハンドクリップショック
これに引っかかることはトミックさん無いと思います
握ってみましょう　ふぅーふぅー　あうわやでぇ！！！！
やばい
一番強い
これやばい
シンプルですね巻き尺
分かっててやる人いないでしょこんなの
あれ？こないな
こなくね？来ないよ
これ多分壊れてるね
ここ引っ張ったら電気流れる予定だったんでしょうけども
不良品かわかんないですけど引っ張ってもここが流れないようになってます
次はこちら
手榴弾みたいですね
これまた握ったら痛いやつでしょ
俺知ってるよ
うわーやだなー
気合い気合い　あいいでで！
次はこちら
ピストルです
トリガー引いたらのやつでしょ　あいだだ！いっだいいっだいいっだあ
もうやだー
車のカギの電気ショックです
どうせどれか押したらまたなるんだろ俺は知ってるよ
サクッといきましょう
ライターです
まかせろ２つ同時にやってやるぜ
はい　ラストです
ルービックキューブの電気ショックです
なんかこうカチッてしようと思ったら電気が流れますやってみましょう　あいでだだであ！　おっほっほっほ〜（涙）
今新居に一つだけ何も置いてない部屋があるんですけども
その部屋にこれを全部セットします
そこでトミックさんをその部屋に入れさせて
部屋にある物が全部電気ショックが流れるドッキリをやってみようと思います
引っかかるか引っかからないかわからない物が多いから
どこまで引っかかるかがポイントですね
彼の知能が低いことを信じてやっていきましょう
よしセットが完了しました
違和感しかないんですけどこんな感じでセットしておきました
部屋に何も置いてないので
違和感は仕方ないと思うんですけども
あとはトミックさんがどれほど好奇心旺盛で
ここにある物に触るかがポイントでございます
はいではトミックさんを呼んでいきます
トミック：なんだよ＾～
トミック：なんかビリビリになるやつ？
はいというわけでもし部屋の中にある物が全部電気が流れる状態だったらでした
はじめ：これとかもここ押してみてください
はじめ：いや大丈夫です本当に　いだいだあっだ！
ははははっははははははあっはは